this video is brought to you by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform
where entrepreneurs can easily create
and customize their own personal or
professional website more on Squarespace
later in the video so hello and welcome
to yet another episode of biographics
I'm your interim host Carl small and
today we're talking about King Henry VII
England's Larger than Life Monarch and
as with all of the videos here at
biographics this one is based on a
script submitted To Us by a member of
our writing team that being Ben Adelman
whose Social Links you can find below
alongside my
of all the kings that have ever ruled
over England perhaps the most famous is
King Henry VII being Remembered in
posterity as a highly sought after
attribute in a monarch though Henry
would most likely not be all too pleased
with the way in which he is remembered
as a fat Tyrant who went through women
quicker than he did clothes and who was
overly fond of chopping people's heads
off he cuts an almost comedic figure
today particularly for having six
different wies which admit is a lot even
in the modern era unless your name is
Rod Stewart and much less so in the 16th
century when he was alive though nobody
was laughing at King Henry his personal
marital troubles spilled over into the
English reformation and the transition
of his country from Catholicism to
protestantism did I you say that
protestantism I've never seen that word
which had a profound impact on Europe
and later the entire world in his time
Henry was beloved by The Common People
any faults in his character were
overlooked and blamed in instead on evil
counselors which explain why so many of
the courtiers that jockeyed for power
Underneath Him ended up on the chopping
block alongside his wives to those that
knew him Henry could be a generous and
loyal friend but everyone quickly
learned to fear his explosive temper
which be triggered at a slightest
provocation when he was angry it didn't
matter how close to him you were you
were in serious danger as several of his
wives would attest to probably his
biggest character flaw was that at some
point he began to earnestly believe his
own hype that he truly was a perfect
monarch anointed by God to rule his
realm and one that didn't really need
the guidance or advice of anyone
underneath him under his Rule the
Kingdom reached the very Heights of
absolute monarchy as Henry leaned more
on fear than loved to keep his subjects
in line This granted him almost
unparallel levels of power and wealth
also had consequences that his
descendants will be grappling with for
centuries after he shuffled off this
Mortal coil but let's start as we often
do with the
beginning
Prince Henry was born on June 28th 1491
in Greenwich Palace to the west of
Central London his father King Henry
iith who saw that one coming had come to
power just six years earlier when he
defeated and killed Richard III at the
Battle of Bosworth field winning the War
of the Roses and founding the Tuda
Dynasty initially he wasn't supposed to
become the king that honor belonged to
his older brother Arthur the Prince of
Wales well everything changed in April
1502 when Arthur suddenly became ill and
died at the age of 15 leaving the
11-year-old Henry as the air apparent to
the throne Henry the 7th died in 1509 of
tuberculosis or consumption as it was
sometimes known back then and after a
short Regency his son was crowned King
Henry VII on his 18th birthday as a
Young Man Henry was largely uninterested
in the day-to-day running of his realm
leaving the business to his advisers
principally Thomas waly Cardinal
Archbishop of York instead Henry spent
much of his time at play the early parts
of his Reign were filled with feasts
dances tournaments and behind the scenes
all manner of sexual exploits Henry was
also contrary to the idea we have of him
today a pretty active Outdoorsman in his
youth spending his time doing things
like hunting playing sports and just
scaring the out of his advisers by
participating in jousting tournaments
with other young Nobles of the realm a
dangerous Pastime that could have easily
named or killed him and later did at
least one of those things as for
appearances Henry VII was about 6'2 in
tall so he towered over most of his
contemporaries and was also considered
to be quite handsome and muscular for
example he had a 50in chest and armor
which still stands at the Tower of
London is among the biggest they have on
display Henry was also considered to be
exceptionally well read this was the
start of the Renaissance after all and
many works of ancient Greece and Rome
were being rediscovered and new
philosophies of thought based on those
ancient texts were being expounded by
learnard men across Europe Henry
considered himself to be a humanist a
student of this new school routinely
read ancient history and contempor works
in philosophy astronomy and history
among other things he also had a
colossal ego a firm believer in the
divine right of kings he was the first
English Monarch to be addressed as your
majesty instead of your highness he
spent vast sums of money projecting his
power and Splendor as propaganda to
Showcase his majes to a culture that was
still mostly literate the things that
Henry would spend money on included was
not limited to clothing and jewelry
massive quantities of food and alcohol
and above all else his magnificent
palaces and Estates which Henry would
spend huge amounts of cash to renovate
throughout his Reign he actually owned
more houses than any British monarch
ever has or
since and I know you probably enjoying
that video but it's time for a word from
today's sponsor but I don't like doing
sponsors and stuff alone so anti to
me today's sponsor is
Squarespace yeah s space I'm joined off
camera by Brad Nisha who threw the an
eer not me okay I you got some spiral on
that an was flying last time I thought
you going to throw into my hands didn't
expect it to be on a radar screen I
thought I'd accidentally like stopped
the recording or something cuz it hit
the computer it's fine it's fine do you
know what else is fine today's sponsor
Squarespace tell me about today's
sponsor off camera Brad Anisha who
apparently have a thing against antias
so Squarespace is an all-in-one website
platform so I'm assuming you've heard of
Squarespace before of course yes because
this is the third time we're making this
recording but so basically you can use
it to create a website so it's a website
that makes websites which is yeah so
weirdly meta I wonder how they made
their website that's one of those things
like how would you make a website that
made a website that makes
websites did do they use like Cube
spaced and then you get into like the
fourth fifth dimension so Nisha you
nailed me with this anti like it sailed
through the air almost as easily as you
will sail through the tutorials on
Squarespace cuz the future is squares
it's just squares that you drag and drop
and Squarespace allows you to just drag
and drop and create an amazing website
maybe about anti years yeah they use
this thing called fluid engine see that
sounds rad that sounds like something to
be in like you know Wave Race like 64
it's like you can drag and drop anything
anywhere so there's no limits it's like
you can customize it as much as you want
you can customize it to your heart's
desire but always within the framework
that Squarespace provides so you don't
have that awful aligning problem you get
on word you like I'm I'm going to drop
an image into my script it'll look it'll
look
great you getting all that with square
space it's all just handled on the back
end for you allowing you to focus on
making your website look as pretty as I
do in this jacket do you know you can
also run your own online course yes if
you want to monetize the thing that you
do online you can like create a
subscription style service to your
website you can like allow for one off
on monthly payment so you want to teach
someone something you think you've got
you've got value to add to the world
like you know if you want to teach
people how to like you know nail
something with an an eater from across
the room you could create a course on
that and like you know it's pretty easy
for me to keep track of the two friends
I have in this room right now let's say
I've got more than two friends and they
like you know so let's say I've got in
this hypothetical world yeah let's say
I've got three 300 friends and they all
come on to my sick website about tossing
an eaters how how do how do we keep in
contact with them
so I'm like lost B just how just just
concentrating so hard so I'm like is are
you talking about mailing list or the
analytics well the mailing list is a
great way to keep track of people you
have a website you want to keep people
informed like your day-to-day dealing do
you have a mailing list but analytics
equal is important though a seldom
appreciated aspect of creating content
online as a content creator myself I'm
well aware that analytics are king and
having just you know a just a suite of
tools that allows you to analyze and
keep them all to hand is incredibly
useful for any website whether it is uh
at the professional or the personal
level there's a reason that Carl's in
front of the camera and I'm here so
thank you to today's host Squarespace
check out ww. squarespace.com
biographics for a 10% off on your first
purchase of a website slain using the
code biographics thank you to
Squarespace for sponsoring today's
video for most of the first 15 years of
his Reign things continued pretty much
the same way as they had done since he
was 18 Cardinal Walley ran the country
in the king's name acquiring vast
amounts of wealth for himself along the
way while Henry and his courtiers were
spending even more to show off and have
fun but the good times weren't destined
to last forever as they often say and
the trouble when it came would be Senter
around the person of the king's wife a
pattern that was destined to repeat
itself many times over the following
years moving back to 1501 Henry's father
Henry iith had made a contract to marry
his Heir Prince Arthur to Katherine of
Aragon the daughter of Ferdinand and
Isabella of Spain when Arthur died Henry
hoped to keep the alliance with Spain by
having Catherine remarry Henry she's a
hell of a sentent Henry wanted to
remarry Henry so Henry V 7 wanted him to
remarry Henry VI eth this required a
dispensation from the pope since canon
law usually forbade a man from marrying
his brother's widow Henry and Catherine
eventually did marry in 1509 right
around the same time they were crowned
King and Queen by all accounts the
marriage between the two was a happy one
Katherine was entirely devoted to the
king while Henry clearly loved Katherine
even though his wandering ey saw him
take many Mistresses over the course of
their marriage particularly when the
queen was pregnant the problem with the
marriage was the couple's marked lack of
success in producing Offspring
particularly a male heir to the throne
despite at least six pregnancy that we
know of Henry and Catherine only
produced a single child that survived
infancy their daughter Princess Mary
this POS serious dynastic problems for
Henry it was considered a King's first
and foremost duty to ensure the peaceful
succession of Power by producing hirs
particularly male heirs a woman had
never ruled England in her own right and
leaving the kingdom to Mary if something
happened to Henry was leaving the door
open to a fight over the crown that
could spill over into Civil War that
could destroy England some thought it
was given to legitimizing the King's
bastard's son Henry Fitzroy and making
him the heir instead but that posed its
own issues that made a smooth transition
unlikely in 1536 that was no longer an
option as Henry Fitzroy died at the age
of 17 after a long illness around the
same time that questions about the
succession were being raised Henry
became infatuated one of the Queen's
ladies in Waiting an Berlin an
intelligent and ambitious young woman
who is said to have had captivating eyes
and who was at least 15 years younger
than Catherine unlike the other women
that Str struck Henry's fantasy and
didn't want to be his mistress to be
used and discarded the way her own
sister Mary had been a few years earlier
she strung along insisting that she
would only give up her virginity to her
lawful
Husband by this point Henry had become
convinced that his marriage to Catherine
had been cursed by God himself he had
married his brother's wife and God was
punishing him by denying him male
children he became determined to end his
marriage to Katherine marry and Bin and
live happily ever after well this was
much easier said than done even for a
king divorce was strictly forbidden by
the Catholic church if you wanted his
marriage an old he needed an excuse so
began what became known as the king's
great matter a six-year Saga stretching
from 1526 to 1532 in which Henry's
advisers did everything they could to
sever the bonds of holy matrimony
between the king and queen within the
bounds of established Cannon law the
official position that Henry and his
lawyers took was that Catherine had lied
when she swore that Prince AR arur had
died before the couple had slept
together in the biblical sense because
the marriage between cathine and his
brother had been consummated it was in
defiance of Leviticus 2021 and should be
annuled by the Pope in the past the pope
may have been sympathetic it was not
unheard of for monarchs to just jet in
their wise for one reason or another and
have the pope kind of go along with it
and an excuse could usually be found or
a loophole or something like that but in
this case European politics interfered
Charles I king of Spain and Holy Roman
Emperor one of the most powerful men in
Europe at the time was Catherine of
aran's nephew Charles loved his aunt and
he wasn't going to sit by and watch her
be cast aside by some fat ass King and
he just so happened to have Pope Clement
I 7th within his power after an invasion
of Italy in 1527 led to the sack of Rome
and the Pope's virtual imprisonment
within his walls the legal case dragged
back and forth for years as both sides
dug in their heels Catherine attracted
quite a lot of sympathy across England
and Europe and was tiess and determined
an assertation that she was Henry's
Legal Wife the bottom line was that the
pope wasn't going to give Henry what he
wanted and since he was God's appointed
representative on Earth he held absolute
authority over doctrinal matters but
Henry was determined to have his way
even if you had to look outside the
Catholic Church to do
so such an open break with the Catholic
Church would have been Unthinkable in
just a few decades earlier Henry himself
had been a devoted Catholic all his life
but he was nowhere near as devout as
Katherine was but in 1517 Martin Luther
had triggered the pro Reformation when
en nailed his 95 thesises criticizing
Abus in the Catholic church to the door
of the cathedral in Wittenberg Luther's
ideas spread across Europe and there
were many reformers in England by the
time of Henry's great matter including
crucially Anne Berlin and her Court
faction after arranging the downfall of
cardinal Walley in 1529 the Bowlings
convinced Henry that he didn't need to
have the Pope's permission to do
anything he was after all the king
appointed by God should that not mean
that he and not the the pope was the
head of the English church so in 1532
Henry did exactly that publicly breaking
with the Catholic Church announcing his
marriage to Catherine was invalid and
marrying and crowning an in herstead
Katherine was banished from the court
and anyone who opposed the New Order of
Things run the risk of being declared a
traitor to the realm John fiser the
bishop of Rochester and Sir Thomas Moore
who was served as Lord Chancellor After
walley's Fall were among cathine
strongest supporters and they suffered
for it when they refused to swear an
oath declaring Henry was the head of the
English church executed by having their
heads chopped off uh King Henry VI's
chosen method of execution for pretty
much the rest of his Reign Henry's
action shocks the rest of Europe and
outraged the pope who had Henry
excommunicated the strongest sanction
you could impose on a monarch by law an
excommunicated King could have his realm
invaded and his crown taken from him by
any other Christian State most people
however just blamed an bin for wickedly
leading the king astray she was labeled
The Babylon among other unsavory things
even when condemning him no one was
willing to actually go against the
doctrine of monarchs being sacred and
exalted beings to make matters worse
after all the trouble he'd gone to to
marry his second Queen things weren't
going so well in the bedroom Department
an was not content to play the role of a
submissive ceremonial queen as her
predecessor had done she continued to be
outspoken about political matters
something which infuriated King Henry
neither was he all too happy when Anne
refused to look the other way when he
began to sleep with other women making a
scene about his Mistresses in a very
public way that was embarrassing to the
king but most unforgivable of all was
the fact that the same childbearing
issues that played Katherine's marriage
to the king showed up again out of four
pregnancies only one produced a healthy
baby Elizabeth another daughter and it
didn't really do anything to resolve
Henry's succession issue while the king
remained popular and's popularity
however was never that high to begin
with and it plummeted during his Reign
all kinds of plots were attributed to
her when cathine of aragan died for
example in January 1536 it was widely
believed that she'd been poisoned by
Anne even though it would later be
determined she died of heart cancer she
made many enemies at court including
fatally Henry's new Chief adviser Thomas
Cromwell Cromwell once a bullant Ally
eventually determined that the queen was
a threat to his own position and that
she had to
go in April 1536 allegations were made
that Queen Anne had been unfaithful to
Henry sleeping with various men at
courts including her own brother George
Lord Rockford by modern standards the
case was a travesty of Justice the only
man that confessed to the adultery did
so after being tortured and it's widely
believed that Anne had been framed that
didn't stop Cromwell at Henry's behest
from arresting a group of courtiers and
having them convicted of treason
adultery of a queen was considered a
treasonous act at the time because of
the dynastic sucession questions an her
brother and four other men were
sentenced to death Henry meanwhile had
already moved on to somebody else Jane
Seymour a woman he'd been csing for
months before the allegations against an
were made h on May 19th an berin was
beheaded within the walls the Tower of
London less than two weeks later Henry
had married Jane the undoing of the
berin faction seemed to bring a sense of
normaly back to court but Henry refused
to be reconciled with the Pope he pushed
ahead with his reforms to the English
church including the most contentious
issue of his Reign the dissolution of
the monasteries over 500 abies
monasteries and other religious houses
throughout England and Wales were
forcibly closed by the king's
Commissioners with all their assets
transferred to the crown and this is
like one of those like it's a pretty St
well studied and stored like part of
history but the actual amount of
knowledge that was lost um during this
period is not really known because it
was lost and like there's some
historians out there that say like this
is the English equivalent of like the
sacking and burning of like the Library
of Alexandria and because the amount of
knowledge that was contained within the
walls of them these monasteries um was
virtually unique and wasn't easily
replaceable so when it was destroyed all
that knowledge was gone too this was not
only a religious matter at a stroke King
Henry acquired 20% of the entire
Kingdom's land wealth more than doubling
the Royal coffers he used much of this
land to in favor with nobility with
nearly every peer of the realm
benefiting from the dissolution he made
sure to keep enough of it for himself to
make him the richest prince in
Christendom however Cromwell who had
engineered the reforms in Henry's name
was richly rewarded for his efforts
earning himself more enemies in the
process as he took the position formerly
occupied by
waly
on October 12th 1537 Jane Seymour
finally gave Henry what he so
desperately desired a son Prince Edward
however child birth was a risky business
for mother as well as child and Jane
died 12 days later probably of
postpartum infection Henry was grief
stricken in less than two years all
three of his wives had died admittedly
he was responsible for one of those but
still those are bad odds eventually
however Cromwell pushed him to marry
again not only for political reasons but
because the kingdom needed and I quote a
spare in case anything happened to the
infant Prince Henry himself after all
had been the Second Son few women would
look at Henry as an attractive match at
this point one potential bride joke that
she would only marry the king if she had
a head to spare with France and the
Empire still cold towards England for
you know allog together predictable
reasons Cromwell turned the Protestant
League an alliance of German
principalities who were sworn enemies of
Charles the and would make good allies
for Henry the Duke of cleaves a small
state that straddles the modern border
of Germany and Holland had two unmarried
sisters and one of them Anne was
considered to marry King Henry when an
of CLE arrived in England Henry was
shall we say less than impressed with
her not only did he her find her
unattractive but she apparently had an I
quote evil smells about her whatever the
hell that means still it was too late to
back out without causing an
international incident so the two
married in January 1540 however Henry
made few attempts to shall we say say
consummate the marriage apparently
finding a task and a quote once again
unbearable at this point Henry was no
price stallion in 1536 he was injured in
a Jou in accident told you he suffered a
leg injury which became infected
probably with osteomyelitis and it never
healed troubling him for the rest of his
days he was often unable to leave his
bed for days at a time suffering
frequent bouts of debilitating pain when
the wound became inflamed the injury
kept him from exercise he had enjoyed as
a younger man and this combined with his
ravenous appetite caused his waistline
to EXP
shall we say a lot no one really said
anything to the king to deter from
getting fatter and fatter and instead
the courts simply started wearing wider
cuts of clothes so they could match his
majesty which actually a common Trend
with English Monarchy I believe there
was one other king who was admittedly
not as fat as King Henry VII but was I
know had considerable courage and they
are believed to be the reason why it is
not considered gentlemanly to button up
all of the buttons on a waste coat right
it's you might see people say you leave
the bottom button of a waste coat
unbuttoned and that was supposedly
started by this slightly overweight King
who couldn't do so himself so other
members of his court just talk to doing
that as well and then people start to
copy you know the aristocrats who were
doing so without realizing the context
and it just became a thing like the
telephone game of History just made that
a thing people did without anyone
realizing the reason why or maybe that's
a completely madeup story I saw on
Horrible Histories once either
way by July Henry was tired of his new
wife and he'd already found a
replacement a 17-year-old Katherine
Howard a very attractive and vivacious
young girl who strangely enough was a
cousin of Anne berin her family the
Howards used his attraction to her to
dispose of their enemy Cromwell who'
taken the heat for an of C's marriage
Cromwell was arrested in 1540 and
beheaded the next month an meanwhile had
been pensioned off given the title of
the Queen's sister and their marriage
and old the queen marrying his teenage
mistress directly afterwards with
Cromwell dead the court split into rival
factions mainly on religious grounds
with the Reform Party led by Edward
Seymour the late Queen's brother and the
conservative party led by the Howards
the conservatives were the ascendancy
because of the new Queen and Henry seems
to be moving away from the reform with
many of his new doctrines resembling the
old Catholic ones by this point Henry
was burning both Protestant and
Catholics for heresy confusing everyone
with what his actual beliefs were then
in November 1541 another Scandal erupted
around the queen it came to light that
only had Queen Catherine not been a
virgin before she married to King but in
fact she'd been carrying on an illicit
affair with one of the king's chamber
servants Thomas Co pepper enraged Henry
stripped her of her title and threw it
in prison in February 1542 Katherine
Howard not yet 20 years old was executed
along with Co pepper and two other
servants the Howards would never recover
from this Scandal and Seymour the uncle
of the future king would basically
dominate the court for the remainder of
the realm in July 1543 the King married
for the sixth time his new wife
Katherine par was a shall we say exper
experienced woman of the Court who had
already outlived two husbands so at
least they had something in common there
a secret Protestant she' survived an
attempt by the conservatives to have her
accused of heresy and apparently serves
as a great comfort to the increasingly
alien
King Henry's last years were spent in
increasing Agony as he began to suffer
from ever more serious health conditions
including gouts as well as a pain caused
by his leg wound his great weight only
made things worse and on January 28th 15
47 he died at the age of 55 he was
buried at St George's Chapel at Windor
Castle next to the body of Jane Seymour
and just some little bonus facts here
about the king's final days that people
might find interesting um for one I
believe every single night before he
went to sleep he would have his servants
brick up his doorway um so that you know
he was that paranoid someone just like
break into his room and kill him and
when he died he had to be put into a
specially made coffin and his body
because of how large and overweight he'd
be being literally exploded in the
coffin at which point some dogs came in
off the street and began eating the
residue that leaked through the seams of
the uh the casket yeah I know I use
casket and coffin that interchangeable I
know a coffin you can take the entire
lid off or a casket has a lid I believe
it was a casket he was in what an
ignominious end for such a famous part
and figure of English History a as for
what happened after King Henry's death
his son age nine was crowned King Edward
I 6 but all effort his father went
through to secure the succession came to
not Edward died just six years later
before reaching his majority the crown
would pass in turn to both of Henry's
daughters Mary from 1553 to 1558 and
Elizabeth from 1558 to 16003 Mary a out
Catholic like her mother attempted to
bring England back into the Catholic
fall burning hundreds of Heretics and
earning herself the nickname Bloody Mary
Elizabeth meanwhile became one of the
most celebrated English monarchs of all
time the Virgin Queen as she will become
known who firmly established England as
a Protestant realm and oversaw a golden
age that set the stage for the British
Empire both Queens are said to rever
their father despite the difficulties
they and their mothers had with him
difficulties is a hell of a way to word
that however after the T dnasty came to
an end history will prove not so kind to
Henry VII and it seems obvious in
retrospect that most of the people who
suffered and died during King Henry's
Reign did so as a direct result of
selfish and impul of decisions the king
himself had made and that his advisor
had merely taken the blame and the
public scorn on behalf of their
Sovereign as he got older Henry became
more tyrannical increasingly subject to
Violent mood swings probably caused by
the pain of his leg injury this was only
made worse by the fact that the more
power he gathered around himself the
more he began to believe he was
infallable every decision he made had to
be the right decision no matter how rash
impulsive or contradictory it was to
another decision he'd already made
simply because he was the king and what
he said when which was probably of
little Comfort to the literally
thousands of people who died during his
reign as a result of being branded
Heretics by the king and his policies
Henry the though ridicule today for his
many wise and rotund vage is undoubtedly
one of the most important monarchs in
English history The Church of England
also known as the Anglican Church is one
of the largest Protestant denominations
in the world with the British monarch
still serving as its titular head The
Strife over religion would divide the
country for more than a century after
Henry's death leading to a Civil War and
the deposition of more than one Monarch
even today a law forbids Catholics from
inheriting the crown until 2015 a royal
who married a Catholic was ineligible to
become king or queen the British Empire
would spread its Protestant Faith
everywhere it went which in the 18th and
19th centuries was pretty much the
entire Globe many former colonies of
Great Britain have large Protestant
populations to this day because of this
including the United States Australia
New Zealand Canada South Africa Kenya
Tanzania and Zimbabwe it's amazing to
think about all the changes made to
world history because one guy really
really really really wanted to get laid
so I hope everybody watching at home
found this video entertaining
informative and educational I certainly
found the script to be all three of
those things and if you happen to enjoy
the video why not go give the uh the
writer Ben Adelman a follow on social
media below and while you're down there
do the same for me you can also find
links to my other channels Wiki weekends
and fact with car Smallwood we're having
all together more um uh casual tone in
these videos as well as links to the
sister channels for biographics top 10s
and Geographics on which I'm also the
interim host as always I'd like to wish
everybody out there you know the day
that they
deserve
bu